what's up guys welcome to meab bit it's
Monday I'm here with Maxwell McGee Brown
hey uh we're going playing Castlevania
Bloodlines today and uh well this is a
game made by Konami came out 1994 for
the Sega Genesis uh it's the only
Castlevania game on the Sega Genesis
which is really quite
shame uh and it's really interesting you
have two different characters to choose
from uh one has a whip as you might
expect the other Spear and he has a
certain a twisty twirly spear we'll see
in just a second and he's got some
really cool abilities that he can do
with his spear um so yeah if you guys
cut over to the big screen right now we
can watch some of the intro to the
story think here we are learning about
dra's
niece yeah so Elizabeth Bartley
Elizabeth Bartley the legendary vampire
that we've all heard of uh you know
she's causing some [__] Dracula's castle
that kind of thing you know the drill
yeah uh and then Simon Belmont fuses
with that woman and they turn into
Castlevania BLT
Lin all right so who we got I'm going to
start off with Eric lard Eric lard with
the alard spear not to be confused with
the alard spear which might be a thing
uh notice his hair is green or like this
blue color but then oh wait for it oh
and there's Dracula
castle castle
Dracula oh there it is oh man and his
blue hair is suddenly
blonde I think it was also blonde in the
quick intro as well it was a last minute
thing they're like American audiences
love green hair make his hair green
during the game if we make his hair
blonde people think he's a lady and then
they won't like it so his fears got
pretty good reach he can do this little
spinny animation to do light attacks on
enemies oh that's so good he's also got
a charge jump he got some Mario Bros 2
jump
yeah uh and here we are classic
Castlevania opening stage kind of layout
going on indeed
indeed according to Wikipedia oh do it
the legendary vampire Elizabeth Bartley
Dracula's niece I'm not doing that voice
anymore suddenly appears in the 20th
century plotting a sacrificial war in
order to bring her uncle back to life
she orchestrates the beginning of World
War I what do you know because why not
Quincy Morris's son John and his best
pal Eric lucard vowed to take up the
fight against evil together they managed
to prevent Dracula's full res oh
spoilers they prevent Dracula's full
Resurrection sorry folks they do in fact
prevent he does not come back poor
Elizabeth Lizzy as call her as Dracula's
niece's friends call
her all right I do not want to lose my
souped up
spear so you're actually fighting in
World War I right now in World War I
Dracula's castle [__] there goes my
spear which was a Strate strategic
holding
for wherever it's located
here we go jump in action who there's
been a guy I can't remember his name
right now but someone's been
speedrunning this game recently mhm and
I hope no one's expecting me to be as
good as him and if you've watched the
show you'll know that I'm not you'll
know that you're not I'm not very good
during live streams
so and I say that only to make you think
that I am better when not on camera oh
man John Morris is born December 12th
1895 in Texas USA good old Texas good
old Texas
America this guy is going to break some
windows in a moment oh or he's not going
to he's going to breathe some fire all
in and about your face that's okay I'll
take the little fire
oh or whatever you call
that you about to tell us a thrilling
antidote about the Stellar window
breaking Tech they developed for this
game
uh
oh got get boned um one thing that's
cool though is that uh this game has a
lot of interesting levels and like
features in there um like stairs like
stairs for one uh but there's like a few
elements that that like animate and
rotate like Sprites in a really
interesting way oh yeah I think we're
going to see pretty early on there's the
uh you're going up the spiral Tower and
the tower rotates around you yes
although yeah well certainly not unique
to this game is still a great visual
it's pretty neat yeah K I've said it
before and I'll just repeat myself cuz
why not uh the team that Konami had
working on the Genesis Hardware was
really really good because they got a
lot out of the
system compared to a lot of other
Studios getting a lot of uh call outs to
the minecart stage and Donkey Kong in
response to your comment about not being
great on
stream the now Infamous infam Donkey
Kong Minecart incident of a few weeks
there is a super cut on Gamespot
yeah I didn't know
that I was awful that's really good but
man like but
seriously freaking mine cart freaking
mine carts freaking Minecart
levels oh you got my
toe oh no oh the sad music oh thrust
upon your own sphere
a so Peter so Maxwell I know nothing
about Castlevania Bloodlines true both
for purposes of the show and in real
life where does this take place in the
greater Pantheon of Castlevania Jesus
entries please summarize the entire
Castlevania line for me real quick well
okay so Lords of Shadow 2 brought it
back to modern day right right so let's
work backwards from lers of Shadow 2 uh
um and let's see this one is what 1893
is that the date that they threw out
there I mean if you want to go the full
story treatment I just more meant like
is this the third Castlevania Game
fourth I think the first three were on
like n this yeah the first three were on
NES and then also a few other Japanese
PCS like the
x68000 um the MSX I think also had a
Castlevania okay um but this was after
Super Castlevania 4 on the Super
Nintendo right and I believe that's
where you had the crazy whip yeah but I
believe before Dracula X on the PC
engine okay or Rondo of Blood as it's
Rondo yeah um look this dude I know he's
a real son of a
[__]
um so yeah I I'd put this somewhere
around ceman number five okay no oh get
that wall my meat the wall meat I got
the wall meat good yeah you're you're
full wall wall cured meat salted wall
meat salted wall meat that was the name
of my Scott ban in high school it's
pretty good uh I'm going to be lame and
just save my state because who wants to
watch me fail right oh look at this
using the
power of the Retron of the see did it's
a good thing you did it cuz like
immediately using the power of the
hyperkin Retron 5 we can cheat in this
video game here we
go cool
cool oh so do you have like two
different uses there for your sub weapon
so if you press just C you get that
standard one if you press up and C you
get that does he use up more Hearts
though if you do the up sure does Max
one the well look at that I love these
stairs in the sky because okay because
why not yeah because
Dracula
soundtrack
what do I got here it's the big night
right so he's from Super castania this
guy is ready to party uh apparently not
yet he just comes marching
out got a good got a good jumping
competition happening here between you
and this guy see who can jump high oh oh
he's a jiggling watch out he's commenced
the jiggling okay no that's cool it's
cool we're
good oh I'm so out of weapons you
managed to knock the axe out of it oh no
he lost histi he's doing the foot he's a
kicker we got a
kicker you need to get out of this
corner bro this corner is not treating
me well oh you got you got ropes he got
him on the ropes he's so done he's so
done Victory jump into
the Magic Orb oh okay you got this time
no one more there we
go going to stand there for a while life
bonus all right this Castlevania also
following the stage A to B structure of
castl vanas of yor indeed instead of the
more open ended Metroid Vania style that
known for some alternate paths but
certainly no map to explore that's for
damn oh there's like for got they like
Forks
like that when it goes out forest all
right so you beat ja's castle okay now
we're going to Greece yeah as you
do and man look at this I tell you what
uhoh I tell you what uhoh it gave me a
password but whatever look at these
Sweet Water effects uh one thing the
Retron 5 has which is kind of useful as
a screenshot functionality which means
that password screen I just saw oh if I
was really smart I could have a
screenshot and said cool that is really
good oh you have save states too so ah
man freaking minut
you got minitar right the RO
there stupid minitar he just doesn't get
it menars just don't get it Max M with
his Farmers Only daing website reference
with the Farmers Only humor for all you
people out there who both watch the
stream And subscribe to Farmers Only or
have at least seen their wonderful God
damn it wow I'm tell we need to get you
can order a Farmers Only poster now and
it says City folks just don't get it
like on the side of a Mason and we could
hang it up in our non-existent studio
back here I do need reminders that
sometimes as a city Folk I just you you
just don't get it Peter you don't get it
I really don't sometimes you know you
want to go sit in your pickup truck and
drink lemonade and figure out where
where the hell Jill Jill's
gone well as I now know Jill spends most
of her time in the field oh yeah she's
out walking the field as always you
think you just
learn Shadow Farm is only if they want
to sponsor meab bit [__] toally hit this
guy
up he doesn't have to be lonely on
Farmers
Only oh this a great
song It's My Time oh I got to [__]
hurry I suppose that makes sense because
the previous stage was a
sunset if you walk too high to the top
of the screen will that also kill you I
don't think so no or will you just not
be able to see yourself sorry you were
too ambitious yeah I know you were a
little too excited about moving up the
screen just go just
go now one of these is like a fake out
it's going to be like an alternate path
in a second now I will say a lot of
people in the chat very curious whether
or not Eric lrad or whatever the hell
his name is lard is wearing a a mini
skirt yes okay way to just put that to
rest oh God what if I look for Eric Le
oh really you're not going to die oh I'm
going to die images on Google Images
what do you get I get well there's a
bunch of pictures of him wearing pants
from that terrible fighting game on the
oh he was in that game yeah
apparently oh I got some artwork here
and yeah Min skirt but I mean card all
the Belmonts he's not a Belmont
necessarily but Belmonts are known the
other you know the the normal cast is
known for wearing
such many skirts that's true they got to
have that free range of motion when
they're climbing all those stairs and
jumping around and whipping dudes
yeah you need junk
unrestricted it's like a Tommy
hillfigure like one of their sub
Brands Tom hillfigure Junk unrestricted
and there's just a bunch of black and
white images of dudes just hanging out
with I guess they're junk un obstruct
unobstructed I guess that would really
be an absence of clothes more than
anything
oh oh you
dick get up
there that minur
minur minur Min tour [__] I got no lives
left so can John Texas USA also do do
all the super jump crazy acrobatics that
Eric lrad can do I cannot do these names
right now no you can't okay Eric lrad so
he's more of just oh I remember this
dude oh such a pain in my ass he's going
to give you the Waterworks unless you're
just going to keep him on lock down
which is cool I'm going to try to but he
gets quicker and
quicker
oh well he kind of gave that one up so
whatever he didn't want to win oh get
him yeah all right
wait a just what's that up there I want
to run into
that there you go yeah nice twirl thank
you they're working on my twirl ribbon n
old boy oh
God it's not
good [__] let him get in the
frame this guy makes a weird
noise kind of a pushover yeah you were
really lightening
up all right that's why this is what's
going
on he's like I'm going to get you this
time this time just stay right there oh
damn it okay okay one more one
more one more oh
greedy me not him of course I will say
after playing a lot of Dark Souls this
is very much a Dark Souls fight you're
having right now teeny tiny person
versus giant autonomous suit of armor I
think there's one more oh no there's not
okay but I'm going to die so fast you
want to save it I mean I just kind of
did but I only have one bar I'd rather
die you're going to fall into the safe
State trap where you have to keep
reloading but you have no Health there's
no oh you know I'm going to die here you
went through a screen transition ser
it'll let you load
up how did those things go through that
building I God damn Adusa
heads what are you doing this is not
what this stream
needs they're the Minecarts of
Castlevania twirl twirl twirl oh God
Peter don't succumb to the Medusa head
oh a [__] it went up and not over all
right I'm going continue one time and
then we'll switch over to Eric Eric
Texas Eric
Texas oh cool all right all right see
there you go see screen transition
you're
good
want to talk about Batman going on in
the Stream not sure how that came up
what are people saying about Batman
oh I think it's because we were talking
about the skirt that Eric was wearing
are talking about Robin now and then
yeah then it got talking about Robin and
then it got said into fictitious
conversations between Batman and Robin
about his skirt so Robin uh we need to
talk Budd let's chat I mean I like where
you're going with this your head's in
the right place you know you want to be
mobile flexible all that stuff breaking
new ground in the world superhero
fashion really got to do this yeah we
have an image to uphold here and uh well
we want to strike fear into the hearts
of our enemies yeah not and the cine
junk un restricted collection really
isn't really isn't doing it oh I
remember this this is great little a
great little touch right here oh oh take
that classic
art I have no respect for you
that's lost Atlantean
sculpture Grecian really well I guess a
wild Mary Kish appears on
set hi Mary
Kish y you get the Gary Oak theme when
you come in here
like how this guy he's got his helmet
on get the rest of the clothes just give
me that loin cloth and that bone helmet
and I'll be send me out to battle send
me out to battle no I don't want a skirt
just [__] oh oh man you just wrecked
that wall though yeah well you know what
a little wall just stand there in my
way we're just
Wrecking
so good Genesis sound effects so
good that old boy he was ready to
go put me in coach [__] I got this one
damn it I was doing so
well
oh like breaks my
heart breaks my heart
e real sad State of Affairs e
e
bye Mary Goodbye Mary Kish bye Mary
Kish
bye go just God get off the set Jesus
trying to do a show that dude's like
well might as well kill myself I mean he
did just watch you push over that giant
statue head that's true he's like I am
not going to mess with this guy I'm just
going to take my chances with the
bottomless
pit
yeah I started watching that meab bit
stream and then I got about halfway
through it and all they did was just act
out sound effects as they happened on
the
show which turned out to be surprisingly
entertaining we should turn off the
sound effects in game what and just do
oh and just Supply our own this turkeyy
is not going to be here I thought you
were talking about the bad guy him a
turkey this [__]
turkey get him there you go where did I
die last time I just fell down like a
stupid hole you fell down the find the
stupid hole and then just Nintendo Power
not Nintendo Power Sega power be like
watch out for that uh dumb
hole stay clear of the dumb hole clear
the dumb hole it was down here it was
down here I tried to and he knocked me
off like a real [__] okay like a real
real son of a bee of a be uh-oh oh my
God oh my God I saw it too I saw I was
looking steps ahead I was like you're
going to jump out of that hole Billy
Billy Club over here is going to put it
to you put the Spurs to you billy club
Billy C Club otherwise Richard Club
founder and CEO of the billy
club which not to be confused by the
night stick weapon I mean he runs a
series of nightclubs called how does how
does Billy become Richard Rich how does
Richard become Billy you're thinking
dick is it oh and William is the other
one damn it I am thinking I'm getting my
nickn nicknames nixed
up my nicknames mixed all hour folks
yeah damn it damn it damn
it there's no wall there's also a whole
lot of YouTube is buying X and Facebook
is buying X humor going on in the Chann
yeah I can't wait until someone offers
me $10 for
megabit it's coming one of these days
just going to cash it
in oh God oh my God you're not going to
get that $10 if you get taken out by
freaking skull heads just give me the
turkey I know it's not going to be there
I just I just want it I just wanted so
bad the original Castlevania games
didn't have password saves did they you
just have to like roll through it uh-oh
whoa
wow Eric Eric Tay unplugging all of the
equipment in the
studio that's great bringing us into the
Dark Void oh is that did someone buy
meab bit did somebody just buy meab bit
about to buy meab coming out here by
Mega he's got the $10 does he actually
have $10 though well he's holding an
amount of money oh he's got 20 look at
that oh man you got to negotiate you got
to drive the price up oh viacom's
offering 25 oh we just Eric we just got
word Viacom they wanted they got 25 for
you really just unplugged the whole
freaking thing didn't you yeah maybe if
Bonito back there we could go to a
commercial a commercial break oh no hold
on too soon Eric Tay bringing it back
saving the stream all right here's what
you're going to save you're going to do
it this time I'm just going to say do I
save though no no just go the chat will
think less of you if you save State they
already think less of
me oh okay okay okay here we go here we
go here we go big money we got to get
that
V John Paul qualcom he wants you to beat
this
part I'm going to beat it like a wuss
down here no it's good you do what you
have to you do what you have to a lard
always does God damn it come on just
just get him you had a whole rhythm
going I know I don't actually understand
how that didn't work out for me I got an
eyelash going oh jeez you got an eyelash
going I know I got eyelash going on not
good oh there we go oh wait no hold on
there we
go
these poor minotaurs just stuck in this
this
Purgatory having to
run maybe we'll get out this time oh no
it didn't work go
down what is this what is going on down
here a boss fight that I'm woefully
unprepared for you are woefully
unprepared although you you rocked it on
the last three boss fights yeah but
those are mid bosses look at this guy oh
look at this
dude
freaking
trying to think of some sort of like
Burger King multistack burger patty but
I can't remember my hamburger hamburger
days did Burger King really have like
they had like they had like the the the
Matt kids or something like that or not
the Matt kids the Matt kids I'm sure it
was called the Matt kids yeah cuz they
just really wanted to cash in on that
McDonald's bread
awareness oh okay okay okay I like that
I like this thing he's got going on here
he's really good at it just like I'm
just going to if stepping on you and the
Rocks don't work out you you can always
just wander in the range of my grabbing
on Double Whopper thank you Chad it's
like a it's like a Quinto Whopper what
is
five cuz it's like double
triple quad Whopper quad and like maybe
Penta Penta Whopper pent I think that's
what it is cuz it's pent kill in League
of Legends if you kill the whole enemy
team
and there's five people on a team
therefore so by the transit property it
must be the penta Whopper so I'm only
putting up with these guys because I
need oh you need to
get horn I need all my resources corn
horned cuz I got those horns impaled
would have been a much better word than
horned yeah I'm going to go with this
one not the ax IDE I know I know I'm
going to save it too think less of me
all you want oh my God ye of the chat ye
of
chat Bob
Jones I'm out of
here you can still run
Eric you can't run anymore
Eric oh wait a minute wait a minute T3
HHH in the chat says this guy is
seriously
chiseled damn bam
nailed it you just won the chat what
does he win Max
oh I'm looking around a free account at
Farmers only.com hey Farmers only.com T3
HHH you no longer have to be lonely
thanks to I don't know why I'm getting
ready to motion behind me Farmers Only
and then a big farmers only logo would
appear behind me register your free
account today assuming you're not one of
those city Folk who just doesn't get it
oh if you're a city Folk yeah if you're
city Folk uh uh first of all yeah one
you're doomed to be lonely forever you
need to you need to you need to get it
cuz currently you
don't guy's a real son of a
[__] oh man T3 HHH saying he's down
with the farmers only thing as long as
he gets a talking dog that means you've
seen the farmer
only you're getting better and better
your points are going
up three
whatever however you say your
name man this is not good so this guy is
going to get all Punchy he is getting
real Punchy right
now oh my ball my
eye you think his horrible callous Rock
hands would not be the best thing they
would not have the softness needed to
caress and soothe his troubled eye gross
his
orbits get him there you go
yeah let me into your body you are hero
of the
people all is going to shake for a while
all right on that note we're going to go
to a quick commercial break uh we'll be
right back oh okay stretch for 30
seconds oh we're going to stretch for 30
seconds we're stretching it right now uh
let's see hold on uh Melo cow in the
chat says he tried a triple triple
Whopper once and it was really impr to
get in my mouth it was really hard to
get in his mouth yeah it was hard to get
the whole thing just all up in there you
know like sympathize I one of the no I
don't
know seems like you could like you could
compress it down into a region size but
then you kind of ruin the whole
hamburger that way cuz your Bread's
going to get all flat and Soggy your
toppings going get all messed up the
sauce is going to come oozing out the
sides what do you do Peter how do you
solve this conundrum you slice it into
four sections from the top and then what
you have is a very thin profile that you
can turn sideways oh right and then flip
it and stick it well we're flipping and
stick yeah uh we're going to flip and
stick to a commercial real quick we'll
be right
back only right I mean it's one of my
favorite sites on I was really I was
just registering sorry we're back oh
okay hold on I'll I'll just stop doing
that for a second okay hey hey hey uh
well yeah so uh so while you were gone
Peter was getting decked by Harpy and
didn't realize it yeah I was too busy uh
belching and looking at my
phone what is uh where do we end up here
um this outside the capital building
looks like we're in oh we're in Italy
yeah cuz the the Tower of because the
Leaning Tower which I think we are
actually going to oh that dude what a
whoa I like that guy I applaud I don't
really like any of them I wish you
weren't on their side well you oh wow
the game is really putting the Spurs Fe
now but I think here in a second we are
going to peruse the the Tower of pie of
perie Y not in Paris folks don't listen
to
Maxwell
I kind of just want to do I test my luck
I feel like the Harby's in okay cool one
of us n no no no that's what happens
Peter this is what happens this is what
happens that was pretty great you're
like do I test my luck that you did it
you had the false Victory got our hopes
all up and then just took it right away
from me all right don't harp on me for
too
long damn it nailed it nailed
it I hate all the harpies man I don't
like any of them get out of here like
you think there'd be one Harpy that I
could be cool with right no they're all
[__] or one of them would just give
up like you knocked the spear out of his
hands he's like okay whoa okay hold on
like okay you guys are real I'm out of
here come on walk into my thing just do
it hey who's a Minar
now
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] don't just
don't just power through it I need power
through it you got to be
strategic you seen how many harpies are
coming at me now you really do need to
get out of
there God
damn damn this gets hard woo woo well
okay what we can do yeah do you want to
switch or do we want to show the twisty
the twisty tower well we can switch and
we can skip levels using a handy dandy
code off the internet if you go to game
let's do oh yeah okay hold on I'll I
mean
when oh you know what I just walked off
the stairs Max now might be a great time
now might be a good time to make a
switch okay game
fact.com
yeah looking for John Morris continue
all right I'll just type that into
search game facts hold on all right
let's just do let's do game Fact kind
Morris no no no that's you want do no no
no no just search for the game okay
let's do it that way and then there's
like a whole section for cheats okay uh
players put it at five blood lines oh we
need the sound check sound
check get some sound effects in
there it's really good I don't know why
more people
don't hey you can put it on expert mode
hey that sounds like a grand
idea uh here we go all right let's go to
level four all
right these passwords for someone who
doesn't understand what's about to
happen these passwords make no sense
empty bird empty bird bird empty bird
empty ax empty bird empty empty Jewel
axe God oh my
God wait this is a crazy password
system
oh that is crazy so empty
bird empty
bird where else are the
birds uh all over the place there's two
birds there's a bird there's a jewel
somewhere right there's one Jewel at the
very end
yeah I don't really know if that maybe
maybe yeah his weapon is the Vampire
killer nope NP did it wrong weird do it
again load it up again sorry John
Morris hey start stage six in expert
mode I'm just saying nope I'm just
saying okay look here you you go and so
empty bird empty bird so let's just
start with that empty bird empty bird so
we got empty there okay now bird empty
bird empty so it's the opposite oh I
think I was missing a bird and then axe
empty bird empty oh axe yeah I was
missing stuff bird and then finally axe
empty Jewel axe ax empty and then Jewel
axe there you go so that should be
it curious how it doesn't just take me
right
there
Whip It Texas
USA yeah kind of [__] kill yourself
all right looks like I was going to play
it's like forget about it I'm well you
know that that kind of sucks honestly
stage six for nothing still here is it
like a passw another section for
passwords over
here start the game at stage 4 Italy
with John Morris in expert mode you
could try that
one it's a different
password it's AA empty Jewel oh AXA
empty Jewel that's that's totally
different you could try that you try
that we were at four maybe we should go
to you want to oh there's one here for
five too with John Morris in expert
mode expert mode going to the Munitions
Factory in chapter 5 whoa these zombies
get messed
up yeah this game had a lot of blood and
quite a bit of Gore for yeah and the
rating for this game is GA really so
yeah ESRB did not really care too
much about what was going on in this
game was it rated GA for com Mischief
God damn
it uh it was for anti vampire
sentiments derogatory representations of
vampires this little [__] there's only
one of
them people saying that maybe the game
and the passwords it's like the wrong
version of the game for the passwords
that we're looking at or the wrong
region Maybe
anything is
possible people noting that John Morris
is not as manly as slab Rock Brick slab
Rock Brick pretty it's pretty good who
the hell is slab Rock Brick I think I
think they just made it up
nice can John Morris attack up nope all
right yeah he's uh cuz he's too much of
a manly man he can jump and attack
Diagon that's about it though he can he
can jump attack diagonal but he can't
just whip godamn these
bats why am I so
distracted maybe it's all the lights
okay see how am I even supposed to avoid
all that glass that's one thing I've
never
understood
look if you were really in draculus
Castle and there was a wolf attacking
you I don't think you'd be able to avoid
the glass and real life either
so oh wait a minute here's another thing
too it says bypass region restrictions
bypass region restrictions hold down the
a button as you turn on the
console although I don't know if that
would necessarily apply to the Retron oh
you know what though when I was trying
to use the built-in like game uni
functionality okay it wouldn't let me
start the game it was giving me a red
screen which is known for being like a
region like lock it's like a some sort
of sh protection yeah so maybe it didn't
like the fact that I was using codes and
I could have got by it using the a
button you want to try that well how
much time we got here uh we still got a
while we got like 20 minutes it's 11:37
oh man you have to put up with me for
next 20 I've not I also wanted to
comment on this but oh damn John Morris
he's got first off I love the
All-American blue jeans he's sporting i
Sport my All-American blue jeans almost
on a daily basis and his coow hide vest
and his coow hide vest and he's just
such he's a huge like Barrel chested
dude he's just like his shoulders are
just like up by his
ears where are your shoulders I know
they're down here I don't have that kind
of shoulder
breath we're not all blessed with such
shoulder breaths it's those Texan
shoulders I get these weak Arkansas
shoulders yeah tell me about it he's got
those sturdy Texas
shoulders damn
it well in fact John Norris also the
founder of Farmers Only holy cow really
that's right he's from Texas surely he
must have done
that oh man now there are so many big
mlar huge well yeah big mlar huge that
one that one's a classic uh Buck plank
chest plank chest that one's pretty good
thick MC run
fast Durk hard pek that one's yeah I
like that and roll fizzle
beef truck slam chest yes oh my God roll
fizzle beef also people saying I
definitely have the CH the hair not the
chest have the hair for the John Morris
cosplay you do you could fit the John
Norris roll I just got I'd have to get
some like of those 90 shoulder pads that
you'd always put in your in your
business suit that I would specific my
business
suit it's just to like really give my
shoulders
The Ripe age of 8 years
old what does he got he's got you know
he's got the cowhide vest he's got the
shirt pants suspenders he's got some
sweet boots going on there and some kind
of a headband situation yeah and a
bracelet or maybe a watch it's real
sporty
headband SL slab squat throw somebody
was already had a first name slab yeah
come on Squad thrust is a good last name
just saying as as far as family names
go it's too bad I can't get help from
that
blood but then I would be a vampire and
I would have to kill myself you would
have to just kill yourself what if oh
man Avant guard Castlevania Game you
load up the game and it's just like
you're a vampire kill yourself yes or no
and it's it's all about the head games
man and what if you say no then what if
it's game over either way it's it's
about what goes on in here it's not
about it's about the questions that the
game makes you ask about yourself it's
not about you get powerups or whatever
there's extra lives if you do yes or no
or
whatever it's just not about that man
it's just not about that you need to
look Beyond and see how it reflects
Society I always scared of the accessory
situation because if you get one you
don't want you're boned unlike Symphony
of the Night where you could just
replace him Reef blast
body or as someone in the chat says if
you say no the game just turns into Lord
of Shadow
too [__] this dude he's ready to party
wo just got that ax he's like yeah I'm
going to get
him this boss this
boss
just go away don't don't got to kick
her always disappointed after playing
Castlevania 4 when there is not a whip
that you can just like you know like
whip it out and then that thing that's
so good he just like and he does it
without moving his hand either he just
hold his arm it's all just complicated
it's all in the wrist it's all on the
wrist
all right I did pick up a one up at some
point so I've got a few lives t with
here male in the chat asking if John
Morris is also wearing suspens and yes I
believe he is but let's pull up let's
pull up some official promotional
artwork oh get to the bottom of this
fashion
mystery Castlevania where we on blood
lines yeah let's take a look here I only
recently got a copy of this game I used
to own oh yeah oh yeah he's all
suspenders all suspenders he's all
suspenders all the
time yeah we do kind of have the same
hair going on
I know what you're going to be for
Halloween a real
Texan um for anyone who lives in the Bay
Area you might be aware of this thing
called Beta Breakers if you don't what
that is is it's a uh it's a run from the
east side of San Francisco to the uh the
left side to the coast and uh you know
but everyone it's like Halloween so like
everyone gets dressed up and uh
yesterday Brett ston of Capcom Unity
right yeah he posted up a photo of
someone ing a Street Fighter 2 Super
Nintendo cartridge costume oh that's
fantastic which is pretty good the guy
looked very happy I'm sure he got many
comments throughout the day also sure it
wasn't 6,000 degrees inside that
costume yeah my unfortunately my bait my
bait breaker's experience was just
finding discarded boxes of strawberry
margarita Budweiser can beer drink oh
AKA mistake in a can yeah litered all
throughout my neighborhood so I hope you
guys out there enjoyed your disgusting
strawberry margarita Budweiser beer
drink thanks for not sharing thanks for
not yeah thanks for not bringing me
any oh damn it you see that one up right
I did saw it fall right in the drink
it's cuz the game has a special
algorithm for if if item thing is over
like hit or water or whatever has like a
90% chance to spawn a one
up
man oh yeah noodle legs correctly
pointing out that uh the candles the
candlesticks in this game are attached
to Magic that is correct they are
suspended by Magic yep much like this
guy got to remember that follow him up
another
boss
I don't think I want that no I haven't
seen you use any holy water it's all
axes and boomerangs for you it's all
axes and boomerangs for me all axes and
boomerangs this Crow he just saw you
take down like that it's my candle dude
superpowered wizard dude and he's like
no I got it I got him where the wizard
failed I shall
succeed wow decked one than done oh
outrage oh in the studio after that last
kill bunch of disrespectful fools back
there I know miserable
pilot no don't get off your
Rhythm my whip is all
short it's not a euphemism John Morris
having some performance issues whoa here
we go almost had a fight on our hands
all this guy wants to do is show up this
guy really is just he's just giving it
away every single oh he's like making
you drown that's what's happening he's
summoning the water I guess I have to
take that there's no other item no
they're going to give me another axe
right well I did last time you you sort
of fell Bird come on bird what you got
what you got damn it he has it all he's
got you all right come on
bird sh two
birds no oh my God just find find your
Center oh wow the birds have followed
you into the Boss
Arena
no what is this madness oh get him you
got this you got
this I want to see you win this fight I
want to see you bring it back and then
the fight after
that oh that was a fake out right there
it's not going to work
out
ah find your
Center open up on him
I know I know you're chancing it bro oh
wow oh wow I thought he' scooted out of
range oh man but you just got to get to
the stage transition it's just right
there is it right there yeah I don't
think there are any enemies yeah you
just go down the stairs just go down the
stairs thank
God this is how I use the stairs this is
guard that go
downstairs you go see now you're good
now you're good well the Medusa head is
going to obliterate you here in just a
second and
okay
yeah
really okay okay okay I'll take it even
though it looked like I was attacking it
was all on purpose you are just you are
so lucky just Crouch oh oh
no all right okay all right okay all
right okay okay okay okay all
right
I really hate Medusa heads too they're
like the out of any video game ever
they're the one that like video G you
just you no but like seriously no no
make your point I was trying to everyone
hates a Medusa yes they are the wor they
are every castania game anyone who's
ever played Castlevania hates them yeah
nobody's ever like oh the Medusa heads
they're really cool right no but they're
never like oh they're oh no big deal
right no one's ever saying like oh
whatever Medusa heads no everyone
[__] agrees they're a pain in the ass
they're the worst it's like goddamn
signway get out of
here that should be the meab bit
t-shirt which is goddamn sign wave get
out of here a picture of Medusa
head also just Crouch Famous Last Words
yes you are correct damn
it all
right all these guys our old friends my
friend's helmet my friend my friend
helmet come on guy
no there you go that's more like
it all right Peter we're coming up on
the 10-minute warning here okay if you
want to do any any try to do any Cheat
Code Central or we could just power
through it well I'll see if I get to a
game over screen we'll try to do one
okay there you go that's my friend slam
dunk
wow
yeah okay secret wall meat coming
up guys we got a secret wall meat coming
up we got wall meat wall meat's coming
up if you won't pay
attention go
away so Peter Remember When we had oh
what the Metal Warriors on the show and
it was the best game ever uh I remember
having that game on yeah and cuz we had
it on right before like Titanfall came
out cuz it was like Titanfall before
Titanfall was Titanfall and now that
Watch Dogs is about to come out yeah
what game would be the meab bit
equivalent watch Watch
Dogs watermelon farmer says shout outs
from San Francisco Peter Maxwell shout
outs to you watermelon farmer
dude he doesn't need farmers only
because he watermelons and who doesn't
love watermelons that's true he doesn't
have to be
lonely unlike
Peter damn
it all
right GTA 2 as a
possible I want something like with a
hacking lean to it though
or you know and there aren there weren't
that many games that had hacking back
then and surely there were some but
probably like in just like a real minor
capacity right
yeah yeah any classic hacking games
maybe hackers the game is that a
thing that would be awful I hope they
didn't make a don't you remember the
hacking sections in net hack yeah we can
play net
hack that won't be totally boring for
anybody all right I can't even get the
wall me I already got it I was just more
referring to you not getting knock no
that's not the place that's not the
place this is this dumb the stupid hole
I need to do is go first yeah yeah you
need to throw him off his pattern or is
it this one it's this one this one don't
go immediately don't go immediately you
have to wait for you have to wait for
him attack and then jump that's what I
did last time and he came backwards what
you need to do is you jump down there
and and then you do you do the whippy
thing where the whip goes all over the
no do the hold on let me get the cheats
out do the cheats real quick we got
eight minutes we got 8 minutes we cheat
Cod hold down the a button as you turn
on the
console oh you're talking about no no no
no that's different that's different
what I was talking about well no uh what
are you what are you going do you're
trying to give me these codes I am
that's different okay whatever whatever
whatever do you want just go to the last
you want to go yeah let's go to the last
stage all right here we go or knows I'll
never see it otherwise here we go start
the game stage six bird at the Versa
Palace empty with Eric lard do you want
to oh wait do you want to go with Eric
or do you want to go with Eric is good
John Mor morison empty bird a empty
Jewel empty bird Jewel mixing it
up oops oops
empty bird Jewel a empty bird
empty [__] that's
Jewel axe empty what bird bird empty ax
empty bird empty bird empty Jewel
axe okay let's get this right cuz I
don't want okay here we go empty bird
axe empty yes Jewel empty wait yeah
jewel empty bird jewel is actually the
second line I don't know what happened
there Jewel empty bird Jewel okay axe
empty bird empty we got that one bird
empty Jewel axe so that should be empty
bird ax empty Jewel empty bird Jewel axe
empty bird empty bird empty Jewel axe
all right I'm pressing a and start press
a and start to exit that's what it wants
right I mean that's what I was doing
before it
must did it but I don't think does that
work I feel like it would have started
me yeah cuz it would have forced you to
be Eric maybe you're somehow not hitting
maybe it's like maybe it's just start
maybe it's really dumb about like timing
a and start together maybe what I need
to do is only hit start cuz maybe it's
to get out of it you hit start and a oh
all
right all right real quick empty bird
yep axe empty okay Jewel empty yep bird
Jewel axe empty bird empty
and uh bird
empty Jewel
axe empty bird axe empty Jewel empty
bird Jewel axe empty bird empty bird
empty Jewel axe these are the ravings of
a mad man oh yeah you just hit start
what all right those are the secrets
castania bloodline don't hit start in a
the secrets of the secrets the castle
proen
proen what the the hell in England an
expert mode on expert mode with
Eric final stage start here we go you
got 5 minutes beat the game here we
go like the blood moon they got going on
out you know what bird some might call
it a harvest moon no I don't think
that's actually a harvest
moon you going to die to the Ravens at
the bridge at the start look how much
health they're taking off though
actually look how much health they're
taking off my god I've gotten hit like
twice okay that did you see that [__]
Medusa head I was I was too busy
nodding my head in shame oh
jeez okay here you don't understand you
don't understand the Perils of expert
mode you clearly have no you got this
cuz you have no experience you just have
to kill you're just you're just hating
for the sake of
hating like just drinking that haterade
God this Medusa head is rocking you
though oh you can hit him you can hit
the Fireballs St the fireball that's
just it I'm not going to be able to even
catch the [__] Medusa you just got to
you I'm sure you have to follow them to
the end of the bridge and then it'll be
everything will be good
that is so
hard
God people telling you to channel the
soul of Vinnie
Caravella he will guide you through this
he beat castlemania over the he he
practiced that game for like five
episodes of
UPF what dude whatever medus it's going
to duck every
time
people
want people in the chat asking for a
dubstep remix of bird empty ax empty
je can you blame them that'd be pretty
good I would like I appreciate that that
was hard work getting that password
system to work oh Max everything's
moving weird whoa why is the game
falling apart maybe what would be great
if this was actually is this how it's
supposed to be because that would be
fantastic it supposed to be oh this is
cool this isn't just like a glitch in
the game this is oh no this is supposed
to be this way this is
cool uh what is it like are you viewing
the game through some sort of skinny
mirror that's reflecting something out
of
perspective oh man you are going to fall
in that hole okay so you're going to
fall in that hole every day of the week
the foreground the foreground is what's
misleading the background is like Medusa
head in this
environment
this is so great this is so great you
have no idea what's going
on there's a platform above you yeah
there you go that's dangerous though you
still got to get
across just look at the background just
when you're making this jump just look
at the backround oh God damn it oh so
hard so good continue one time unless
expert mode doesn't give you any
continues which would be great if it
didn't oh why cuz you want to quit well
it's 1158 I'm just saying I'm just
saying I'd rather I'd rather be doing
something else it's not my show you can
keep going if you want to do
it I'll sit here and watch you play
Castlevania all day and feed you
nonsense passwords and look up John
Morrison's questionable
suspenders shout outs to miserable pile
of secrets in the chat he appreciates
our
labor nice real nice real
nice so
confusing I bet there's a cheat code to
make this this like the whole game the
whole game is played in this
Viewpoint I would die so many deaths
more than I already do oh oh cuz it's
different this is Sinister this is
Sinister in
Star Peter do you think you'll ever go
back to Donkey
Kong you do the mine carts stage um I
think I should I feel like that should
be a that should be like an event you
need to like promote that ahead of time
what I need to do is yeah what I need to
do is use it on the Retron cuz that was
the last time we used the old setup with
like the video delay the slight input
delay which okay I believe accurately
blamed my incapabilities on right so I
you want to do it again with a proper
proper setup yeah I want to prove that
I'm not [__] at
games even though we all know that that
that to be the case watch watch your
feet I don't know I don't know how you
do that I don't know how you did that
just go just go no I need to jump
because if I just go that's what
happened last
time
and now we are officially moving into OT
we are moving into OT moving in OT as
Peter attempts to beat Castlevania blood
lines expert mode with Eric wonderskirt
Eric wonderskirt Eric uh Eric what was
it what do we call it the Calvin Klein
oh junk unobstructed unstructed I was
going to say unrestricted junk
unobstructed
line where even are you I bet there's
like just a big room that you can't see
if there like a thing and it says just
go here to finish the game but you can't
see it cuz the perspective is all messed
up no you can't just do that Medusa head
you can't just go into a man's game like
that and knock him down a bottomless pit
in expert mode on Castlevania blood
lines oh the the stage actually starts
out
aligned and then as you walk forward it
gets worse until it reaches this
threshold now it's just all effed
M pile Secrets advises that you enable
vsync to correct the screen tearing
that's happening right
now oh all right this is the last life
all right I'm calling it I'm calling it
do it do it wow do
it oh
man I like this up thrust you got going
on here that's
pretty use the TL when you get to the
Medusa has you got a whole but where
there's one there's always more max I
know if I spend time that's true they'll
just keep
coming such a weird mind [__]
okay
what people in the chat we need you to
send Peter Brown your love and support
munchow Goku asked for the people of
Earth provide him energy everyone send
me your energy for the spirit ball we
need you to send your spirit energy to
Peter Brown so that he can make these
jumps and not get knocked into pits by
Medusa heads and then complain to me
about it all day damn it maxb I'll
complain to you about things all day as
much as I want got to get to the thing
there you see it was all you chat oh and
yeah perfect because your spirit and now
everything's upside down everything's
upside
down people though asking perhaps you
should clarify again that this isn't
like for one we're actually not playing
on emulator oh no no we're playing the
Retron 5 we're using the actual cart the
actual Sega Genesis cart and we're
playing on the Retron 5 we plugged in in
front of us here so it's not like any
sort of technical issue with any of the
hardware in to set up this is is how
this is the insanity of level was level
eight wow and wow well you got through
it sort of sort of you got through that
part we got through the stream y uh cool
well thanks for watching me fail
admirably once again admirably you
always do it admirably thank you thank
you uh once again you guys are watching
Mega bit come back later today at 2 pm
for multiple players with Ye Old
Christopher Waters Christopher wats what
is he playing today I have no idea he's
not what golden ey golden eye playing
golden ey cuz it's video G History Month
very appropr uh so yeah thanks for
watching Everybody Max McGee thank you
for joining me as always always a
pleasure appreciate all the color
commentary and Farmers Only jokes also
shout out Farmers Only
seriously make an account today and if
they want to sponsor the show let us
know don't forget city folks just don't
get it city folks just don't get it
thanks for watching Everybody Take
Care
by